[Music]
Everyone's thing,
ready
to electric your eyeballs.
The
flu that makes dreams
come true Thank you for coming to this live stream
Today, we're delivering a video to everyone all over the world
[Music]
It's sunny in the Paldia region today.
I don't want to go,
but Choro is a famous person,
so that won't come true, right
?  Announcement
Who is the random buddy
Game good yay
The challenge city this time is
[music]
Everyone watching the stream In other words,
you The
rules are very simple
What
kind of Pokemon
is
it
?
I wonder if there's an image of it moving a bit slow
What
does it look like? Well, it looks like there are two cats, but a
lot of people mistake them for eyeballs
.
That's because I'm the leader. That's right.
Speaking of electricity, my
body expands and contracts and generates electricity in my stomach.
In the next broadcast,
everyone's predictions are getting more and more
buzzing It wasn't that
until the next broadcast, I'll be posting more and more on what kind of TV is
it? Please subscribe to my channel.
Tattane
[music]